I actually have a lot of prostitutes
walk around my neighborhood at night and
I know you're supposed to say sex worker
now but I feel like I've given them
enough money I should be able to call
them whatever I want but sex is just
such a strange thing you know like we
all have sex we like sex you guys have
sex please send me a video you know sex
is fun we like it but if you charge for
it all of a sudden there's a stigma that
weird sex is the only thing on Earth
that gets sadder when you go pro
huh nothing else is like that maybe
bowling
h isn't that weird about bowling my
friend is a great bowler that's cool
here's my other friend is professional
bowler Ah that's a
shame either way bowling or prostitution
holes are getting fingered in an
alley